[Music]
hey bart
you tend to get very upset i'm not going
to attack you
so defensive okay i was going to say it
just the way i was raised
no um okay you tend to get really hot
right very very hot you're a hot person
especially do you
ten temperature temperature yeah yeah
yeah i'm sexy too [ __ ]
you want to kiss me
so when you fly in an airplane do you
ever get like really stuffy like
i get really hot so usually when i'm
flying on an airplane i'm either wearing
a tank top or a t-shirt
or um i have these joggers that are
really cool like when you zip the sides
it almost ventilates through the legs
like 2
000 style yeah because like my my ball
sacks get
[ __ ] like how many do you move it to
only thinking about your ball
but it's like two ball stacks he has
four walls huh
you have four one ball sack two balls
nobody get
separate never mind
it gets really really hot like my back
gets hot so like
yeah so i try to wear as like light
clothes as possible
it doesn't get cold like this
i feel like once it's in the air about
an hour or two
that's when it gets cold because they
blast it like crazy
and also when you get on it you get it's
colder up there i always make sure i
have a
some sort of over i'm always going home
and like i almost want to bother my
neighbors like a pointed at me
i've been on a flight where i was like
give me like almost
like it was so hot and stuffy i'm the
type that has to have a water bottle
with them because for some reason i'm
extremely thirsty as soon as i get on a
plane and the thought of not having
access to water
type that will freak out i'll be like
this stays with me and i don't need a
big-ass thing of water but i'm like
i'm gonna die of dehydration because i
have a dry mouth or something yeah yeah
and then i start feeling claustrophobic
because the air is kind of stuffy
but then there's some flights where i'm
like i'm okay
i'm just chilling i'm a little cardigan
and i just go to sleep
because this class feels different
though it does it relaxes you
when you breathe when you got to sit
close to somebody i'm like
we went to last time in hawaii um you
guys came on the plane late i thought
like
you guys were the last people to get on
a plane so i was sitting in the middle
seat and there was no one next to me i
was like oh thank god and i'm kind of
like bigger than
some people most people most people
proud of yourself i was like
okay [ __ ] as long as people sit next to
me like they're like i'll be
okay um and then i just see the two
biggest hawaiian people come
400 pounds plus and they look at me like
[ __ ] like this everybody looking at each
other like oh this [ __ ] likes it
right
in the middle of us and they sit next to
me and they go like this they're they
like they need it they can't even help
it
yeah and they were just you just felt
[ __ ] shouldered the whole time it
felt comfortable
but it was just like oh so everybody
look at each other like oh bro what you
want to eat
what you wouldn't eat yesterday
yeah but i could imagine do you guys
feel it like the friction and the sweat
oh yeah
i was wearing like clothes but do you
clothes yeah yo my
dad is a bigger guy so he gets like
claustrophobic in planes
because of that like he's just thinking
the same damn thing
but they keep paying the extra he's like
yo [ __ ] this [ __ ] like i'm not gonna be
squished up next to somebody
my dad will be walking the plane getting
drinks from the stewardess having
hole-blown conversations just so he
doesn't have to sit down
just so he did as soon as the light
comes on my dad's like
i'd be like dad he's like so this is
your auntie
auntie coming up on the plane giving me
extra drinks i was like dude who the
[ __ ] is she he's going
into now and i was like okay you just
wanted to get up and
walk around cleaning passing water out
to everyone
i ain't sitting down no matter what i
love flying with my dad because my dad
remember when they were talking about
weight restrictions on planes they say
almost saying like you needed to put how
much you weighed
yeah how much does he weigh a lot like
300.
i think so what is a big guy he's like
six two he looks like a football player
like he's big my dad's a big like my
dad's a big dude my dad's like not a fat
guy my dad is like a
song he's tall and yeah big be
softer my dad says my dad's not quite
rock
he's like soft wrong underneath this is
rock at the dad at your insulation
the rock got it from you dad he's gonna
watch this like oh you like call me fat
oh no wait i could tell the size because
when you all take pictures together he
makes
you look like a little girl yeah wow
that's why i like big guys
yeah it makes sense because it's like he
i was like damn
that guy must be huge like six what he's
like six two see but six two is not huge
true big a big guy but when i wear heels
we it's his frame my dad makes me look
like i'm yeah my dad
has a big frame i look like a smaller
girl well going back to you feeling
claustrophobic and you feeling hot in an
airplane
did the thought of like you guys walking
up to the exit row
opening the door walking onto the wing
of the plane just to
get some air ever across your mind oh
we're in the air
not in the air oh not in the air just
like just chilling
no i'm not no you see the big red sign
that says don't touch me exactly you're
right
karen's in the sky i also take
the laminated instructions they make
really good fans
true i've thought of needing to stand
up to like be like out of the area but
i'm not
touch it first off don't touch myself
open the emergency room
let me tell you guys this lady oh hell
no of course it would be a lady please
tell me what her name is
i don't know her name karen karen is she
care is she karen esque
uh i would say probably okay so
uh they were traveling on a ukraine
international airlines ukrainian karen
ukrainian that's scarier
[Laughter]
yeah so they were going from turkey to
back to
ukraine she got her teeth done and
like like yeah she was traveling with
her husband and two children
and she they were sitting at the back of
the plane
and this [ __ ] was like it's just too
hot she walked from the tail
of the plane all the way up to the wing
and then
opened the emergency exit and just
strolled on out there
on onto the lane and so people took
video of this they're like what the [ __ ]
is happening someone play the video
what a great example for our kids yeah
oh my goodness where is she
absolutely small she's sitting down
stop she's enjoying the view
i'm surprised she's not taking a selfie
she's just chilling it's too hot she was
sitting down
she was known so nonchalant though she
in heels
i don't know i know that's a small
little door
i hope that you're first off cute outfit
[ __ ]
or she's just massively tall i almost
wish the pilot was like oh [ __ ] we
parked in the wrong place and we gotta
move and have to turn the jet turbines
on and she's like oh yeah
no oh the audacity
they must do it different out there
because she had no fear first off
zero i said the way this skin color
touch we not opening no doors no no no
if she was asian she would at least took
her shoes off and walked on
how rude exactly so rude and then
so this ended up mm-hmm i hope they gave
her like a fine
well 20 lashings so they
they banned her from all future uia
flights
but she could fly other flights oh yeah
like that specific airline she's banned
from
and they said that they should be oh
they also said
that the airline went on to criticize
her for setting an inadequate parental
example
and that she may be subject to an
exceptionally high financial penalty in
form of a fine
wow yeah you're not supposed to touch
the emergency ex
clearly that wasn't in america did she
get up maybe she was like this emergency
i'm so hot yeah she said it's just too
hot that's bull
first off i'm going through the front
and out that door that's already open
i'm not opening no extra doors
no was it her first time flying i don't
know the way she
no the way she's dressed she literally
has done this before and the [ __ ]
didn't get first class this time so
she's so
she's wearing a cute ass flying outfit
nobody looks that
like they're all together outfits there
are flying outfits
yeah what's the flying outfit well i i
do know all the things yeah it's when
you wear the leggings they say juicy on
the back
yeah that's like people i don't know you
know what i don't own those
and you're well you don't fly enough
that's not mine like they just nice in
europe when they fly
like when i'm out there i feel like a
complete garbage yeah but in america i
feel like i fit in oh you should see the
guys now they dress like [ __ ]
they trying to impress someone on the
plane sometimes i
i think it's cool sometimes i like
stretchy clothes so you're talking about
what qualifies as like a decent flying
outfit yeah
so i prefer this could be one depending
on where i'm going
say i gotta go somewhere right off the
plane and i'll take my i have like a
long cardigan or something so i'm warm
on the flight
but still i look okay i can't do
flip-flops because i do the slides
so yeah or like if my feet are exposed i
can't i used to be able to be okay with
that there's too many germs around but
then now
it's the germs thing and also my feet
just get [ __ ] cold like
i'm covering them up no
even now i think i have bad circulation
because
my when i go up into the sky and then
come down
the my my ankles get really really
swollen
and so now i have to take pictures of it
swollen ankle
from landing the airplane the air like
the air pressure like the pressure
difference yeah she gets ankles when she
comes down yeah i get cankles that's
now you got a stretch on the blade i get
that in hawaii i thought it was just
like the sodium
well that's a personal problem it might
be the sodium if you think it's a sofia
you should get uh compression socks they
help a lot it still happens well like
when i wanted turkey nothing i was like
checking because i was like every time i
go to hawaii
i get my but after like a few days maybe
it's the walking
it's a spam music not not flying you're
talking about when you're
in hawaii yeah oh it's a spam
you're definitely eating too much sodium
do i have to put the voice on
like you already know you see everybody
else walking
yeah they're either surfing or paddle
boarding but you literally just from the
flight alone no guess what yeah every
time or
when did it start i don't know it
started maybe if you got up and walked
around to probably help out because you
just probably need
that's the blue i can stay in like an 11
hour flight and not
and maybe get up to go pee once you're
like the exact opposite of this lady
but i drink water in the same spot yeah
exact opposite exactly
i try to know where i'm going as far as
like where am i landing and what's the
temperature
and what am i doing that will determine
the outfit because i'm like sweat
hoodie if i'm heading to new york first
off it's sweats it's hoodies it's a
comfortable sneakers
the socks and then i got like the big
overcoat depending on when i'm flying so
i'm ready coats ready
go get off the plane do what you need to
do flying to la
flying to l.a just doing a heat wave i
am wearing
i look decent just in case someone
recognizes you i hope
somebody would hi um i definitely will
take a photo with you
no but but certain like certain airlines
certain places
sfo i'm just getting the [ __ ] in and
getting out like i'm everything is
hidden i'll put the ball cap on all of
that what's wrong with sfo
sfo you get in you get out it's kind of
colder in san francisco
so when you fly into the bay you got to
know it's colder so
i can be i can be in la so i'll be in la
tomorrow then fly to the bay it will be
a hundred and something here
and it could be 64 degrees when i land
yeah
so you just got to know where you're
going but i like comfy clothes no jeans
hell no no jeans are you trying to
address tsa friendly
i just because half of my dress is just
like i don't wear belts
right they're like functional things
that i could just take anything off
yeah this is honestly this is one of my
go-to things i throw this dress on i'm
comfortable enough i don't look decent
if my future husband sees me when we're
sitting in you know next to each other
then i'll be ready i don't need makeup
though i don't put makeup on to go to
the airport lots of moisturizer
now it's bad because i'm not so i was
sitting next to this girl and then we
didn't really talk much because she was
in the next row
but on the way out and through customs
and everything we started talking
and from here super cute but you
couldn't tell with the mask right
and i couldn't i was like i want to show
the teeth off of my eye i just got these
done
oh it did it was like you know how you
do it you go oh thirsty so you take it
off
[Laughter]
um
you're just like oh my god
i've been licking my lips like just
naturally on camera what the [ __ ] you're
trying to be
like no it just became natural and then
like i feel like
it draws attention to the teeth but it
happened actually without me even
thinking about it i was like oh these
[ __ ] boys they
they implanted something in my head so
what happened when she took off her mask
so i didn't see that but then we
exchanged instagrams and everything and
then we were there for like half an hour
together right
she said my future boyfriend's playing
let me at least make sure this is cool
and she got
when i got got in the car and then she
accepted it and then i saw it i was like
completely it wasn't bad but just way
different than i was thinking you had a
whole nother vision in your head and she
let you down yeah
did the teeth not match hers you got
reverse catfished
so you liked her in person and you saw
her instagram you're like
first and more important it is all
that's important obviously that's a
conversation
topic that is what was wrong with what
if you like somebody in real life but
you don't like their instagram
i don't give a [ __ ] about instagram yeah
that's good you changed your opinion
about the girl after you saw her
because she can't see whole thing it's
her whole face that's what it is
but it could be different could her
personality her personality shine i'm
all for personality i'm awful
personality
but i think you're attracted to who
you're attracted to wait so what was
going on that was not what you pictured
the prettiness
[ __ ] i was like you lied to me but you
just barely saw
30 of the face right how did the rest of
this make it
right so you saw the body you saw
everything else you got a general idea
enough to exchange instagram
yeah she was dope instagrams oh so
like really like the noise the skin
okay so are you afraid that she might
watch this no she won't watch this
um but you saw the instagram are you
still in communication with her or was
the instagram a killer
kind of killer did you unfollow
no i don't know she was super nice it
wasn't even like
there's so many girls on instagram i
could be talking to anyone do you wish
you got that
30 minutes back you wasted 30 minutes of
your life no
there's so many girls on instagram i can
talk to anybody it's my choice says
every dude
in my comments there's so many girls on
instagram but i choose to leave these
hearts over here for you
there's a lot of girls on instagram but
i rather go mountain
biking there's a lot of girls on
instagram who don't look good in person
you